[Music]
what's going on guys you know every year
the Oscar nominations come out and
people are furious at the Academy so we
here at screen junkies are continuing an
our proud tradition of making our pics
so everybody can get mad at us
- so what if we got to pick the nominees
for this year's Academy Awards and to
throw a little wrinkle into things to
add a little bit extra we didn't just
stop at nominees this year for the first
time ever we voted on a winner our first
category is Best Supporting Actor now to
say that the deliberations were intense
would be an understatement
first category Best Supporting Actor we
all came up with these nominations
independent of each other right off the
bat we have two nominees not included
Academy Award nominations wasn't Snipes
and Willem Dafoe now in the next two
names that had three votes so 50/50
support Shia LaBeouf honey boy Joe Pesci
the Irishman there the next two and then
we have a couple twos and then a bunch
of ones
Mark Dacascos I'd like to a positive for
mark because I was in a movie with Mark
called the The Lost medallion where I
played one of his henchmen I think you
just demonstrated a great example how
the actual Academy really oh I played
off with that guy now in exactly
I shine a buck for honey boy I'm gonna
yes and he'll stay Joe Pesci is three
votes I'm assuming Joe Pesci days
Brad Pitt has two votes on the scenic
ride Penn State no Spencer explain
Pikachu Pikachu Pikachu
stole the heart with every frame
he was on camera did that not make you
want a Pikachu more than anything else
you saw this year Sonic's ear but
Alessandro Nivola I would like to just
pitch Alessandra's I think this is a
really cool leg struggling actor makes
good story you know his last big role
was stealing a pterodactyl a drastic
mark 3 yeah and now he's doing the best
comedy performance of 2019 I think you
know that's the kind of thing the
Academy can really get behind one good
story
I'm out of votes so I assume probably
none for know jew-- fantastic young
actor we now have two names for the
final slot Alessandro Nivola all right
so it's Joe Pesci gets the final vote so
there we go after final deliberations
your Best Supporting Actor nominees
according to us our Willem Dafoe the
lighthouse Shia LaBeouf
honey boy Joe Pesci the Irishman Wesley
Snipes Dolomites is my name and song
kang-ho aracite we only have one in
common with the Academy Joe Pesci and
the screen junkies Academy Award choice
for Best Supporting Actor is Shia
LaBeouf Congrats Shia there's no trophy
but the congrats on you know bragging
rights I guess let's move on to our next
category this one is Best Supporting
Actress here's how it went down
there's one pick though that seems to
have majority support right out of the
gate
another Oscars snoby Jennifer Lopez for
hustlers so I think we put her through
she already has the support of for the
six of us since Laura Dern is the only
one with three votes do we put it
through or do we want to discuss
oh yeah Billie lourd for book-smart
Billie lourd is this weird mystical puck
like character that just keeps popping
up in their narrative and she's like the
definition of great Supporting Actress
but that movie divine Joey Randolph from
Dolomites is my name all right yeah
we've got two three there
Julia Fox unkept Jim you headed to their
party so damn
jail shoes in Xiao Xuan for the farewell
anybody want to single out anyone in
particular they want to advocate for I
mean I really think Julia Fox is there I
could believe she was passed over for
the Oscar like without without her
you're just following this this crazy
guy he's spiraling out of control she's
she's what keeps it grounded in like
recognizable outside the diamond
district well I would like to advocate
for both Scarlett Johansson in Jojo
rabbit who is in a fantasy movie really
the only person living in the real world
and plays that so beautifully and then
Taylor Russell for waves has to take
over a whole damn movie in the middle of
the movie it's incredible and it carries
it makes that transition alright let's
see where we are after this you can vote
for one key Julia Fox
uncut gems or well that does it then
that's that's your finalist is Julia Fox
from uncut gems and your nominees for
Best Supporting Actress are Laura Dern
marriage story Julia Fox uncut gems
Jennifer Lopez hustlers parks oh damn
parasite and divine joy Randolph
dolomite is my name once again when we
had one nominee in common with the
Academy Congrats to all the nominees but
there can only be one winner and that
winner is Laura Dern Congrats Laura Dern
you got yourself a hypothetical award
you know it's not getting any easier
folks this next category is a doozy
Best Actor check it
we actually have some front runners here
there are three people who received five
out of our six nominations locking
Phoenix for Joker Eddie Murphy for
dolomite is my name Adam Sandler for
uncut gems now we have a four vote
person Adam driver do we want to put him
through or do we want to further discuss
all of our all right here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna star Leonardo
DiCaprio right now Leo DiCaprio is our
fifth nominee
however if anyone wants to advocate for
one of these choices taking Leo spot
then we will entertain your arguments
it's unsettling his leave face is made
out of horizontal lines he's but it's
smooth at the same time someone on a
subreddit made like a better reason that
you give John Williams his career star
wars score this year for the same reason
you give it to Return of the King you
give it to Robert Downey jr. for
carrying the MCU for ten years well
anyone be Joe's second-in-command every
one on my left amount is actually about
this Robert Downey jr. comeback or will
he be snapped out of existence we've
talked about our Irishman we've talked
about our Iron Men now we've got to talk
about our Rocket Man talk about Jared
Edgerton he gives a fantastic
performance in that he does do his own
singing we gave it to rami malek and he
didn't sing and I feel like Taron
Egerton
did comparable acting and he did the
singing we gave to Rami well the Academy
Spencer tell us about the beach boat
matthew mcconaughey much like Plato's
allegory in which our reality were only
seeing the shadows of things as they're
cast against this wall by the lit fire
in this dark cavern but if we were to
emerge from the cave and see things in
their true form they would be blinding
to us that we couldn't quite take it
every McConaughey performance up until
now has been just a shadow cast on a
wall this is my combination all of this
blinding ratings the peak McConaughey
the ideal McConaughey it sounds like
you're describing like Nicolas Cage and
Mandy exactly is anyone gonna back
McConaughey after that yeah so here's
what I think we have even though
DiCaprio was seeing the mountain did
we've been persuaded to keep them up so
I think at this point we have a straight
up and down vote between these three you
can only go for one our fifth slot
leading under DiCaprio takes the fourth
slap and your nominees are Leonardo
DiCaprio once upon a time in Hollywood
Adam driver marriage story Eddie Murphy
dolomite is my name Joaquin Phoenix
Joker and Adam Sandler uncut gems we
matched three out of five with the
Academy but then we went ahead and added
a couple of Saturday Night Live alumni
Eddie Murphy and Adam Sandler the winner
taking home our hypothetical Best Actor
Prize Joaquin Phoenix
Joker Joaquin I know you're doing a lot
of damage this award season and your
award shelf is it getting pretty full
but clear a little more space and just
imagine the great trophy that would be
there if we actually had trophies for
this so many contenders only five spots
here's the conversation that went down
about Best Actress Florence Pew for
mid-summer not for
weapon for she's nominated for an
Academy over from its summer has five
out of our six nominations so I think
she goes through so congratulations for
an Oscar nominee not your best
supporting actress but invest actress
for us also too with four nominations
aquafina for the farewell Lupita Nyong'o
for us
bing-bang-boom we have three nominees
none of which are nominated for Best
Actress this year at the Oscars so we're
already blazing new trails now Jessie
Buckley from Wild Rose I thought she was
fantastic I'm the only one that's seen
well okay
saoirse ronan for Little Women yes yes
okay Spencer you like to crawl well it's
just a perfectly acted genre film the
Academy overlooks Elisabeth Moss her
smell Sasha Ronan is definitely through
yeah yeah we could say that now Renee
Zellweger has three Elisabeth Moss has
two so King Phoenix gets nominated in
the real Academy and our fake Academy
and Elisabeth Moss does not I mean I
won't do anything extreme
let's do I have not seen her smell yet
so I cannot in good conscience move for
news over here because I have not seen
Elisabeth Moss the flip of you I have
not seen Judy so why are you know
Danielle I think you're the decider here
now who did you vote for your best
actress nominees are
aquafina The Farewell Lupita Nyong'o us
Florence Pugh midsummer Saoirse Ronan
Little Women and Renee Zellweger for
Judy our picks have two in common with
the Academy and our winner by the widest
margin of any of our votes the pizza and
yong-go for us
Congrats Lupita this is a benchmark I
bet you'll never forget
hey guys let's see what happened when we
talked about Best Director little boy I
believe we can put Greta Gerwig through
a little women yes bong joon-ho or a
parasite yes and the safty brothers
Benny SAP tea with four votes so there
we go so that's all the once was a
majority of votes two votes keeps it on
the board and then we'll debate
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's see where we are after this round
you can only vote for two Quentin
Tarantino Once Upon a Time Hollywood
three all right there we go
Dotel but if you're like an every frame
a painting person every frame yes yeah
absolutely
four names two spots what do you think
one vote for one and one only Lulu Wang
okay
Alma hurl honey boy to Quentin
Tarantino's Hollywood - all right this
is a travesty and you're all gonna
disagree with yourselves when you see it
but Sam Mendes is gone we're left with
two directors two spots they those are
your finals the nominees for Best
Director according to us our bong
joon-ho parasite Greta Gerwig Little
Women
Alma her el honey boy Josh and Benny
safty the safty brothers for uncut gems
Quentin Tarantino for Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood this time around we had to
in common with the Academy Quentin
Tarantino and bong joon-ho and our
winner Alma her L for honey boy Alma you
weren't nominated for an actual Oscar
but you won this Congrats anyway it's
not hyperbole when I say that this is
the biggest I mean it's it's the best
picture it's the one they do last at the
Academy Awards we're doing it last year
here is us talking about Best Picture
nominees just like in the olden days we
don't choose eight or ten or whatever we
choose five and five only looking at the
nominations we have three films that
have majorities majority support those
films are parasite uncut gems and once
upon a time in Hollywood the Irish stays
the lighthouse stays Jojo rabbit stays
little women stays book-smart
stays Joker y'all are gonna look back on
this one and be like damn we did there's
something to be said for a film being of
its time and I seriously think that you
will look back I'd be like can someone
describe what like people were into it
what like it felt like to be part of the
Granton superior piece but alive and
around in 2019 it's the Joker that is
our moment in film history is a super
gritty hot take generator starring a
Batman character this is the ultimate
2019 bill
[Applause]
Wow 19:17 I'm telling you I'm telling
you you were gonna look back on this
video and say what was I thinking
1917 is the peak of what's possible in
the cinematic art form that's all I'm
gonna say we now have three movies two
spots pick one of these films and only
one of those to vote for and let's see
where we are
dolomite is my name honey boy the
Irishman oh wait how can we have five
total votes voting just Joker you
realize by not voting that the Irishman
is automatically eliminated
ands us by default dolomite is my name
and honey boy you go into the best
pictures we would be thrown into sheer
chaos if you voted for the Irishman all
right well we're in the exact same place
where we were which is that all three
movies are tied I mean IRA the Irishman
was a goddamn achievement and it there I
know people say oh yeah score says he's
done a million times but the
late-in-life parables and storytelling
of this like Death Comes for everyone
that is a note in this film at the end
with
euro as he's doing the mundane stuff it
just adds a richness that hasn't been
seen in any of the other mob epics but
also that guy doesn't like a man soweth
honey boy you have to mean achieve
something really special because it's
shadow both not only wrote it it is
based on his life and based on his
experience when he was going through
rehab he plays his own abusive father in
that and he does it in a way a movie
like that can so easily just be up its
own ass but instead it actually feels
very raw and very vulnerable this film
honey boy is a film uniquely for to be
recognized in this year gnome it is
unlike any other movie released this
year it's unlike any other movie that's
going to be released in any other year
and I think it is a singular achievement
in filmmaking
everyone for honey boy honey boy sorry
Irishman he got whacked and our Best
Picture nominees are dolomite is my name
honey boy once upon a time in Hollywood
parasite and uncut gems now despite the
Academy having four more nominees than
we did we only had two in common
parasite and once upon a time in
Hollywood and the winner after an
extremely close vote parasite your best
picture of the year according to us
Congrats bong joon-ho I agree with what
bong joon-ho said about subtitled in
foreign language films if you get past
the 1 inch tall letters on the screen
you're gonna expose yourself to a lot of
great filmmaking but do not expose
yourself to great filmmakers I still
can't get within a hundred yards of
Martin Scorsese there you have it if we
pick the nominees that is what it would
have looked like and you have the
winners see all the movies see the
nominees see the winners see movies that
were nominate just go to the movies
watch movies oh boy
don't you love the movies thanks for
watching everybody I'm Hal Rudnick hit
me up on Twitter bye bye
you